la belgique interdit les voyages non
essentiels à l'étranger à partir de
mercredi sont visés les voyages de
loisirs ou d'agrément
il y aura des contrôles aux frontières
avec des amendes
les travailleurs frontaliers ne sont pas
concernés la belgique est l'un des pays
européens les plus durement frappé par
la pandémie plus de 20000 morts dans le
pays et lié aux coronavirus ont déjà été
recensés la réaction de gilbert b janish
médecin anesthésiste et président de
l'association belge des syndicats
médicaux
c'est une décision je dirais
compréhensible du point de vue des deux
responsables politiques il y a des
nouveaux variants du virus et ils en ont
peur mais personnellement je n'approuve
pas cette décision je trouve qu'on va
trop loin dans les précautions par
manque d'organisation et d'anticipation
je pense qu'on a atteint la limite dans
ce qu'on peut supporter comme société en
termes de restrictions mais visiblement
il n'y a pas d'autre solution aux yeux
des autorités donc c'est ce qu'il faut
subir pour ne pas avoir une troisième
vague et donc comme le disait notre
premier ministre
si on tient bon encore peut-être que la
suite sera plus plus facile à vivre pour
l'ensemble des belges